What's going on here in Los
Angeles? Let me tell you.
California governor Gavin
Newsom just released
a four-tier system to guide
the state's reopening.
Now, Los Angeles is
still in the bottom tier,
which means we have a long way to go
until things get back to normal.
Now, some people still feel
that governor Newsom is
reopening California too slowly.
And of course, people on the other side
think his new system is appropriate.
But I figure the easiest way to tell
how things are in Los Angeles
is just to take a look outside myself,
and judge what's going on
during this period of COVID.
I'm gonna do that right now.
The best way to find out,
just check for yourself,
see how Los Angeles
is doing.
This'll take a second.
(mournful music)
(people screaming and shouting)
(container thuds)
(explosion booms)
(horns blare)
(tires squeal)
(explosion booms)
(sign whistles)
(people screaming)
(dramatic music)
(water tower crashes)
Little more time.
(shoes stomp)
Didn't like that.
I don't frankly know where the
tarantula invasion came from.
That surprised me.